"Lange keinen so schlechten Jour-
nalisten und Beitrag mehr gesehen."
"Wie ist das Leben
als Marionette der Satanisten?"
"Wie viel Geld kriegst du?"
Dies ist das Q&A zur Reportage
"Der Teufel mitten unter uns".
Sie hat hohe Wellen geschlagen.
Wir haben fast 1'000 Kommentare
auf YouTube
und über unsere privaten Kanäle
erhalten.
Einige davon
machten uns wirklich betroffen -
z.B. all jene, die sagten, wir
würden die Opfer nicht ernst nehmen.
V.a., weil genau das Gegenteil
der Fall ist.
Es ist uns sehr wichtig,
dass jedes Opfer ernst genommen wird,
man diesen Dingen nachgeht und
man ihnen die richtige Hilfe bietet.
Die Opfer dieser Verschwörungs-
erzählung sind Betroffene,
die in diesem Gedankenkonstrukt
der satanistischen, rituellen Gewalt
leben müssen.
Es ist wichtig,
diese Menschen zu stabilisieren
und ihnen die richtige Hilfe
zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Es ist gefährlich, wenn ein Therapeut
das Erklärungsmodell
einer satanistischen Gruppe
im Untergrund bringt,
die sie jederzeit wieder
missbrauchen könnte. Das schadet.
Trotzdem muss man die Betroffenen
ernst nehmen,
das ist uns klar.
Wir haben viel Mitgefühl
für Missbrauchsopfer.
Viele Leute fragten,
warum wir keine Opfer
zu Wort kommen liessen.
Für uns war von Anfang an klara
Wir wollen Opfer nicht der Glaub-
würdigkeitsdiskussion aussetzen.
Das passt nicht zu uns.
Es ist schrecklich,
Opfer so einer Situation auszusetzen.
Das macht der Verein CARA.
Er stellt die Opfer auf die Bühne
und sagt, sie sollen erzählen.
Das finden wir schlimm.
Das muss aufhören.
Von den Schilderungen von
Betroffenen zu diesen Ritualen ...
... nährt sich
die Verschwörungserzählung.
Das wollen wir nicht unterstützen.
Nach der Reportage
haben sich auch Opfer gemeldet,
die genau das erlebt haben.
Es wurde ihnen in der Therapie
so eine Geschichte erzählt.
Die Opfer schrieben mir persönlich
und ich muss sie natürlich schützen.
Aber da steht z.B.:
"Genau das
wollte mir ein Psychiater einreden."
"Ich machte mich dann aus dem Staub."
"Ich bin jetzt noch verwirrt,
warum mir das erzählt wurde."
Wir haben die Namen der Psychiater
und gehen diesen Fällen nach.
Viele Leute sagten, wir seien
nicht objektiv und voreingenommen.
Z.B. dieser:
Wir finden, dass es gefährlich wäre,
einer Verschwörungserzählung,
wie wir sie schildern,
unvoreingenommen und objektiv
zu begegnen.
Die Idee, dass es im Untergrund
einen Satanistenzirkel gibt,
der Kinder quält,
ist eine Verschwörungserzählung.
Wir müssen eine klare Haltung haben.
Wir können auch nicht davon ausgehen,
dass es sein könnte,
dass die Erde flach ist
oder es rosarote Elefanten gibt.
In diesem Falle ist es gefährlich,
einer Verschwörungstheorie
mit dem Gedanken zu begegnen,
dass es das ja geben könnte.
Unsere Recherchen zeigen klar,
dass es sich um eine
Verschwörungserzählung handelt.
Das sagen auch unsere Experten
Georg Otto Schmid und Marko Kovic.
David Oesch
fragt in seinem Kommentar:
Das ist genau das Problem:
Es gibt immer wieder einen Grund,
warum das nicht geht.
Hätten wir den Schlüssel gehabt,
wäre es die falsche Tür gewesen,
oder die Person,
die uns den Schlüssel gegeben hätte,
würde mit den Satanisten
zusammenarbeiten.
Auch wenn wir alles
mit Baggern ausgehoben hätten,
hätten wir am falschen Ort gegraben,
weil der Bauleiter z.B. auch
zu den Elite-Satanisten gehört.
Wir kriegten eine Nachricht
von jemandem, der schrieb:
"Die Ruine Duggingen
gehört dem Kanton Basel-Land,
für den ich arbeite."
"Mein ehemaliger Chef
ist der Kantonsarchäologe
und hat die Burg restauriert."
"Er würde sicher gerne bestätigen,
dass es dort
keine unterirdischen Gänge gibt."
Ich bin überzeugt,
dass die Antwort niemandem ausreicht,
der an die Verschwörungstheorie
glaubt.
Es wurde auch ein paarmal
der Vorwurf gemacht,
dass wir die Täter schützen würden.
Wir denken, dass genau das Gegenteil
der Fall ist.
Die Geschichte der Satanisten,
die im Untergrund
Kinder quälen und missbrauchen,
lenkt von den wahren Tätern ab.
Wir finden es wichtiger, dass
die Polizei die wahren Täter sucht,
anstatt irgendwelchen
Verschwörungserzählungen nachzujagen.
MasteroEl schreibt Folgendes:
Wenn die Interviewten
von ritueller Gewalt
oder rituellem Missbrauch sprechen,
schilderten sie
genau diese satanistischen Rituale:
Menschen- und Tieropferungen,
Blut trinken, Menschenfleisch essen.
Darum sprechen wir von
satanistischer, ritueller Gewalt.
Frau Schwager sagt,
wir hätten sie falsch repräsentiert.
Sie spreche v.a.
vom organisierten Missbrauch.
Sie sagt aber auch,
sie könne Tier- und Menschenopfer,
brennende Kreuze und eine Elite,
die im Untergrund Kinder missbraucht,
nicht ausschliessen.
Genau das ist das Problem.
Es ist wichtig, dass wir nie
von Einzeltaten sprechen.
Wir sprechen
von einer Verschwörungserzählung,
die besagt, dass es weltweit
satanistische Zirkel gibt,
die im Untergrund Menschen züchten,
quälen, foltern und sogar essen.
Wenn diese Verschwörungserzählung
von Menschen geglaubt wird,
die mit Missbrauchsopfern arbeiten,
dann wird es wirklich gefährlich.
Wir wurden natürlich
mit den Fällen Marc Dutroux,
Epstein und Fritzl konfrontiert.
Diese Fälle sind tatsächlich passiert
und sind unglaublich schlimm,
aber das hat nichts
mit einer internationalen sata-
nistischen, rituellen Sekte zu tun.
Die Fälle, die man aufklären
und nachweisen konnte,
brauchen
die Verschwörungstheoretiker,
um ihre Erzählungen
glaubwürdig zu machen.
LA und noch weitere sagen,
wir seien das
zu emotional angegangen.
Das ist ganz klar Teil des Formats.
Das ist "rec.".
Das ist ganz nahe am Reporter,
an mir.
Für mich
war es wirklich sehr emotional -
dieses Gefühl,
dass an wichtigen Positionen
Menschen sitzen,
die an diese Verschwörungserzählung
glauben,
dass es eine Elite im Untergrund hat,
die Kinder foltert und Blut trinkt.
Das hat mich
in meinen Grundfesten erschüttert
und brachte meine Realität
zum Bröckeln.
Das fühlt man und das sieht man.
In diesem Format darf man das sehen.
So unterscheidet sich "rec."
auch von einem klassischen DOK.
Isidor Huber schreibt:
Es ist sehr auffällig,
dass Verschwörungserzählungen
v.a. im Internet
sehr stark vertreten sind.
Man muss sich bewusst sein, dass das
eine sehr laute Minderheit ist.
Leider lassen sich aber viele,
die gute Kommentare schreiben wollen,
davon vertreiben, weil sie keine Lust
auf Diskussionen haben.
Ich erlebe das selber.
Es ist anstrengend,
sich dem auszusetzen.
Aber wir dürfen den Verschwörungs-
erzählern nicht das Feld überlassen.
Wir erhielten aber auch
viele positive Kommentare -
z.B. von Cyrill93, der schreibt:
"Ich bin schockiert von der Doku,
aber v.a. auch von den Kommentaren."
"Vielen Dank
für die megaspannende Reportage."
"Wie kann es sein,
dass in der Schweiz
paranoide Verschwörungstheoretiker
als Therapeuten,
Polizisten oder Lehrer
ihre abstrusen Theorien
weiterverbreiten dürfen?"
"Liebes SRF,
bitte verfolgt das weiter."
Wir werden weiterhin recherchieren
und euch auf dem Laufenden halten.
Du kannst uns durch Liken,
Teilen und Kommentieren unterstützen.
Wir sind erst am Anfang.